well we had a fairly broad conversation
in the book about that about family
structure in particular and when you
look at the changing family structure
the most interesting thing is that it's
changed unevenly so you have this huge
explosion in divorce in the 60s and 70s
but that explosion really stopped and
then reversed for folks who are college
educated folks who are middle class and
upper middle class but then for people
who aren't for people who you know have
a high school education or less actually
the divorce rate remained persistently
stubbornly high or the rate of folks who
are having children outside the context
of marriage remains quite quite high and
that has all kinds of implications for
reinforcing class divides and I think of
that as a really big problem but of
course there's another problem of this
kind of radically changed set of
economic circumstances that is led to
wage stagnation not only for the bottom
half of the population but actually for
most of the population during the bush
years workers with a college education
saw their wages stagnate it's quite
extraordinary and you know we always
hope that innovation will save us but
well what if innovation doesn't actually
save us in the sense of creating you
know tens of millions of well-paying
middle-class jobs particularly given
that we're living in a world in which
you know you have this so-called global
global labor glut we're living in very
different circumstances yet again our
institutions haven't evolved quickly
enough to accommodate that and that I
think of as a real threat to the
American working class
I definitely think that the interests of
business and the working class could be
aligned but you know it's very
complicated because for example you're
looking at an environment in which when
you look at corporate profits they were
oftentimes flourishing by virtue of
investments made in other countries
where there are lots of attractive
investment opportunities whereas when
you're looking at the american workforce
there are a lot of liabilities there are
a lot of liabilities and all first world
workforces given that you know you have
an older age profile you have a skilled
profile that oftentimes isn't quite as
resilient so I think that that is a way
in which it appears as though those two
interests have diverged to some degree
at the same time I think that you know
it's useful to think of these things
that's not entirely separate because
again members of the American working
class start businesses and I think would
start more businesses if you had an
environment that was more conducive to
grassroots entrepreneurship when you
look at China they have this kind of
interesting dilemma where in the 80s
they had you know very rapid economic
growth just as they did post the 80s yet
then it was very broad-based you saw a
lot of in rural areas and it was fueled
by grassroots entrepreneurship whereas
since then it's been fueled by
state-owned enterprises and foreign
direct investment in America we have a
similar thing where if you don't create
an environment that's conducive to
people kind of you know trying things
and failing starting new businesses then
you actually have situation where you
know people are at the mercy of kind of
large employers and you don't have the
level of innovation that could
theoretically create those dramatic wage
and productivity games that we actually
need so in a weird way what I want to
see is more a culture in which business
of the working class or not these to
kind of separate entities but rather
very kind of interweave in which more
people who kind of come from a
working-class modest background feel as
though you know I could actually start
something that's going to make a
contribution to the world so that's sort
of a different way of looking at it but
I think it's the right way of looking at
it
you